[Music]
sup guys today we have another mi the
[ __ ]
conundrum so Thank You Redis we got to
call it a CC corner kumquat cutoff
corner controversy controversial corner
okay I like that Thank You reddit and my
the [ __ ] you guys are a bit you're
saving us you're saving us so this is
the guys who's asking am I the [ __ ]
for not letting my mom meet my son I'm a
gay man married and my husband and I
have just become dad through an open
adoption our son was born six days ago
both of my parents are not accepting of
my sexuality they're very vocal about
their thoughts on LGBT plus people and I
didn't want to come out to them until I
was almost 23 and I was still living
with them at the time they kicked me out
and spew a lot of hatred toward me I'm
practically fully estranged now last
time I heard from them was for my mom
was five years ago and my dad about six
years I gave up I speak with my sister
occasionally who's pretty accepting and
my grandma who was amazing and doesn't
talk had into it and has taken her my
husband under her wing as well oh yeah
mom so good good on the grandma in this
particular case my mom takes young my
mom text me two days ago asking if I can
meet her grandson this is the longest
text message I've received for whoa she
said that despite the fact that she does
not agree with my choices my child is
her grandchild and she wants to meet him
and be a grandma to him at first I
didn't know what to say but I just told
her I don't think it's a good idea and
that was her his nice way of saying no
she replied that's unfair of me to do
that to her and that she is still her
grandma grandma and she has a right to
have her fill her grandma duties then
she said myself right to this shot no
this is the best part then she said my
son needs a female figure in his life so
I should do what is right for my son I
appreciate that he is but he is her
grandchild
but it's hard to say yes to someone who
hates me as I am is very actively in
locally anti LGBT how does she find out
that that was a grandchild
with your family Facebook the sister of
my sister mountain didn't look back so
there's that too that's pretty [ __ ] up
says I'm right and she can't expect to
come in and out of my life as she
pleases my husband isn't super
comfortable with the idea of her meeting
him considering it's been five years
since I spoke to her and suddenly she's
interested but only but only in our
child a bear but only in our job he also
thinks it can't do any harm to let her
meet him again
but is very hesitant about it so is he
the [ __ ] I think he's not yes yes the
mom reminds I think he's a big [ __ ]
[ __ ] the mom reminds me of my mom
because so I told my mom I think after
high school I think I'm tired of your
Buddhism [ __ ] I'm not gonna [ __ ] go
with you to the temple or anything like
that and I stopped like reciting these
Buddhist and Confucius proverbs to me
and she's like fine I could respect that
and I'll catch her in the backyard with
my dog Tyson and then he'll be with
she'll be whispered in his ear I'm a dog
which is like it's like this Chinese a
Buddhist chat she's teaching your dog
Buddhism yeah that's your dog man that's
[ __ ] up so I get not Chinese in
buddhism is reincarnation so so he's
just a dog right now but he could have
been my uncle in the past I'm just going
around like doing Buddhist chants to the
dog hoping that she can send up to
through [ __ ] enlightenment or
whatever he can convert me back some
other time
oh my god she was trying to channel
Buddhist scripture through the dog so
that so you can lick your [ __ ] arm
and give you Judith dude to be against
Buddhism now as a kid is so funny like
it's like that's like being gets your
stone or dad hey daughter dad like stop
it up straight in smoke is between but
it is kind of the same thing with like
your if you were like a rebelling
against your parents like Christianity
right it's like Buddhism derive the same
right but yeah in this particular case
this this lady sounds like a [ __ ] like
hug her like you have no like in she's
not entitled dear kid in her defense
though I mean his kid and so it's a one
he adopted yeah or as it was born his
fence that could be her dumbass way of
trying to offer like a olive branch
sure yeah but she still has like these
things in here where she's like she's
not she's not apologizing to him about
the other things the other things that
she's done she's old it's hard for her
to move away - it's like hey I hate you
yeah can I see your kid not tonight
luhan's your future child where is he
that's how I feel like my dad would
communicate and so I'm like I just gotta
do my best to try to see past him be an
idiot am i okay he's trying to make a
man season because him to really try it
my parents were against Nikki yeah I
would destroy them this guy this guy is
a great this guy is way more patient
than I am yeah by destroyed my flame
thrower I would take away anything I
would take I would kill my grandma just
Dean my mom my grandma isn't a mom's
best friend so I would kill her best
friend oh when is that point though when
you decide that your girlfriend is more
important than your family that
girlfriend ask my wife no before that
though there was a there was a point
where you're getting to know Nikki right
and then she becomes your girlfriend and
then she becomes your wife a wife makes
more sense but there's got to be a part
in that process where you're like now
you're more importantly my dad could
suck my dick as good as my wife does but
you know what I think he sucks to give
it head I've always thought that since I
was three thank you for watching the
last refuge for free speech of the
[ __ ] Internet jiggy chair does things
to you doesn't it weird I watched dad at
Sun porn now sometimes the Sun turns
into a tentacle monster and I kind of
like that one because I said mister that
is a good question as though like when
do you choose your lover over your
family members because sex frankly is it
cuz I've had some pretty good sex but I
still haven't chosen my family it wasn't
that good the bomb is [ __ ] it's back to
your life really I think you've had some
bob sex by the way I've heard I've heard
a lot of your
I love my family that's it's difficult
to if you think sex is temporary it's
gonna be good for maybe 20 years any bad
side cuz Hornet horniest people on earth
or people but I think it makes it easier
when your family's being a dick to leave
them yeah yeah me and my in my case I
don't I don't I never really had that
where I'm just like I'm feeling like we
can't connect with your mom or your dad
as much as you can like a chip that
you're [ __ ] really good I don't think
well that is true but makes it fair I
also feel that laughs and scoffs suck my
dick is good you're right right right
but at the same time though you're
married right so there's that
this is family now so then your wife is
family that you're creating extremely at
that girlfriend stage you're not there
yet so then it's I think a lot more
easier to bond more with the kin then
the then the girlfriend unless you don't
have a great relationship with your
family already yeah like in this guy's
case doesn't have a great relationship
with his family well cuz if my mom was
like denying me and kicking me out of
the house peace out [ __ ]
she already have them I never loved you
look there's a lot of that man
especially religious families like I
know a chick who her family was so
religious and crazy they basically
banned her from all things in high
school and she became like a gangbang
chick one are you kidding go she'd be
like a gangster or you mean like a porn
game bag like she did that [ __ ] to get
off because that's how [ __ ] repressed
she was sexting is crazy well religions
great dad approved for porn
yes but the life maybe no religion gets
the girls to do the reverse gangbang
which was the harem style when it's more
girls than one guy oh yeah that's
Buddhism
is this true yeah yeah I think I've seen
cartoons of Christians it's when they
want a lot of guys Hey look at the
church what come on what happened dude
that it is really crazy though it's like
okay when you're growing up right
sometimes you can outsmart your parents
and you're you're kind of surrounded by
these cavemen and you're like what the
[ __ ] how do I like get out of this well
are your parents
most people will if they're not idiots
right and we talked about this to the
college students like it's the same
thing like we were just in Austin and
they're like how do you deal with
parents not accepting this in this and I
was like okay pretty much you guys all
outsmarted your parents you're smarter
than them they don't have that type of
ability in their mind to think
critically so what are you gonna do at
this point you either [ __ ] move out
or accept the fact that they're not
gonna change their mind and most parents
frankly are unremarkable okay like if
more people do so right yeah yeah then
they would understand that they can win
right instead of like oh well my parents
don't approve me so I think I'm a
[ __ ] instead of that if people like
my parents are [ __ ] losers and so but
no one could admit that I know I know
but stuff that's the hard part it's like
does your from your pants so you think
like yes part of them know I'm telling
everyone a my parents included and and
most of your parents they're idiots
unremarkable really when I said my mom a
picture of Steve and I know this is my
new boyfriend and we just made out in my
first thing my mom sends is three dots
and she texts back
think of your wife and her family you
must resist temptation like this is my
mom's logic yeah your mom you were
tempted by a man like me well the fact
that your mom believes that you're Loki
gay yeah I like myself this is not a
self esteem fair the fact that you Bart
a [ __ ] human statue we're tempted by
me Steve a guy who's wearing merch
[Laughter]
[ __ ] mind I have an I watched that's
a loner I'm wearing a loner I wife
because my trainer wants to make sure
that I workout because he thinks I'm
such a piece of [ __ ] that I can sure
won't be honest right about your stats
to back up you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
and we're at a Mexican restaurant at
7:30
like that's why I have an eyewash like
that is just nuts to me so I get jealous
of the kids that grow up with actual
sensible self-aware intelligent parents
cuz I'm like you [ __ ] you got
guidance you have no yeah because I
think the norm is people tend to kind of
evolved from their families and they
want to find another set of family
members or friends that to be around and
then they get stuck in this circle and
then they kind of get they have to kind
of what do you call it like believe and
drink the kool-aid too or else they feel
left out but in reality they were right
they just weren't in the right crowd if
your parents aren't don't have the balls
tell you that you can win or they they
have the audacity to tell you that you
can't that's even more reason to realize
how unremarkable they are that that's
all that I'm saying yeah if they have
such low self-esteem that they have low
expectations for you for you for you to
go out there and make make a life for
yourself and what you want to do then
yeah that really says a lot about their
own self confidence in the bucket that
use it as a motivator to [ __ ] get out
of their agent yeah yeah I was in a
bucket that's a you know it's ancient
its Asian thing you didn't know that
you never got a crap bucket no I mean a
bunch of crabs down in context
[Music]